president microrna France has once again
called the banners to help in the fight
against climate change speaking at the
UN climate change emergency summit he
said he understood the frustrations of
the millions of school children who had
been striking on Fridays texts amended
my him each week for months and months
now we had young people speaking and I
think they've identified as absolute
urgency that we have to respond to here
but while Mac Horn understands their
frustrations his government didn't seem
too keen on those climate activists who
protested in Paris over the weekend with
some alleging brute force was used by
the police as the violence spiraled out
of control
[Applause]
and Matt corn has made it clear he
really wants the protesters to go away
well from France at least as what he
really really wants is for them to take
their anger out on another EU country
Poland marching every Friday to say that
the planet is burning that's nice but
that is not the problem people should go
protest in Poland
help me move those I cannot push forward
map wounds upset that Poland is refusing
to commit to an EU target to be carbon
neutral by 2050 hence blocking the book
from adopting this as official policy
that's not gone down well in Poland with
a country's Deputy Foreign Minister has
accused macron of lecturing and he is
perhaps difficult to swallow such a
lecture when France itself has been
accused of falling behind on tackling
the climate emergency France is missing
emissions targets in three or four big
sectors a wise person once said people
who live in glass houses shouldn't throw
bricks advice some may counsel macron to
take Charlotte Dubinski RT Paris
you